it's no secret that on a day-to-day
basis most people claim to lack the
motivation necessary to make any
significant positive changes in their
lives it's almost a meme in today's
culture that people are just generally
lazy and unmotivated helpless against
their own primal desires to veg out and
scroll Instagram cringing at the very
thought of dropping the phone and
cleaning their entire kitchen every once
in a while though something triggers us
maybe it's a deadline a post we saw on
Instagram or a Tony Robbins video we
just happened to stumble across on
YouTube and it gives us the adequate
inspiration needed to perform the
actions necessary for improving our
situation but here's something that
almost nobody knows action is not just
the effect of motivation but also the
cause of it most people only commit to
action when they feel motivated to do so
and they only feel motivated when they
feel a certain amount of emotional
inspiration emotional inspiration gives
us the adequate motivation to perform a
constructive action but there's a huge
problem with the system aside from the
issue that inspiration seems to strike
us randomly and unpredictably there's an
even bigger problem often our negative
attitudes towards our bad situations
hinders us from experiencing any sort of
emotional inspiration towards changing
the situation in the first place if you
have an attitude of massive guilt shame
resentment or fear towards your current
situation then the very thought of
confronting this monster is likely to
inspire the very emotions that put you
in that situation to begin with it's a
catch-22 so how do you fix this well by
realizing that emotional inspiration
adequate motivation to constructive
action is not a linear sequence it's an
endless loop and you can start wherever
you want to start inspiration leads to
motivation which leads to action which
leads to inspiration which leads to
motivation etc if you lack the
inspiration or motivation to take
constructive action then do something
anything really that harness the
reaction from that action to give you
the adequate inspiration and motivation
to take further action and you might be
thinking well how am I supposed to do
something without any inspiration
whether you realize it or not you do
this all the time ever notice you're
much more productive after taking a
shower and getting dressed did you have
to have some sort of big inspirational
epiphany in order to take a shower no
it's just something you do some actions
require little to no inspiration
whatsoever and those are the very action
whose reactions you should harness into
taking further action
so next time you're avoiding some huge
thing you got to do don't just sit there
and wait for inspiration to head just go
and do something then harness the
reaction from that action to give you
the adequate inspiration and motivation
to take further action and this is the
dosomething principle hello if you like
this video then you will love mark
Manson's article called the dosomething
principle this entire video was based
off of that article was not my own
original thoughts those are mark
Manson's thoughts I'll put a link in the
description for that article down below
if you guys don't already know mark
Manson's also the article of the article
he is an article mark Manson's also the
author of the subtle art of not giving
up which is an awesome book highly
recommend it the link in the description
is there for you to click on it's also
an Amazon affiliate link so if you want
to help out the channel by purchasing
that book or anything else through that
link you also give me a small that's
like probably $2.00 or something but it
does help if you like this video hit
that like button if you like videos like
these in general hit that subscribe
button if you're into self-improvement
and productivity that's what this
channel is all about I have videos just
like this coming out on the regular so
if you don't want to miss it
hit that subscribe button and also hit
that Bell icon which will notify you and
I upload a new video also this was a bit
of a different style of video so if you
dig it let me know in the comments
section was it a good change or not was
it not very good that's all for today
thank you for watching and we'll catch
you in the next video